for best original screenplay the oscar  goes to  for relaxing times make it sanctuary  time i'm pregnant what should we do i  just want to tell you all how happy i am  to be back in the studio you're the guy  in the hole never laid eyes on it'll now  i get people off i look for the one guy  who isn't getting off and i make him get  off americans traditionally love to  fight his name is django he's a free man  you gotta show people that nobody can  get away with this not a priest or a  cardinal or a freaking pope she doesn't  even know who i am can i help you find  something sir definitely  definitely  three thousand dollars on 20. that like  that could break us romeo romeo my lady  my love what do i call you do you have a  name yes samantha then peoples don't  give you any bother in that street today  not at all should their friends their  families see them as us i just kicked  the left foot